there's a concept called Collective
illusions that I think is so integral to
the whole stigma of UFOs Collective
Illusions are behaviors that we engage
in publicly that contradict our
privately held beliefs because we think
you think the same so for instance in
the 1960s most Southerners were against
segregation but they thought their
neighbors were for it so they're like
I'm for it MH and then everyone just
became for it so it's like this
Collective illusion yes this is why I
contend the idea that we have a stigma
in UF ufology I don't think we have a
stigma problem I think we have a coward
problem because the professor many math
and physics professors come to me after
be like okay now that we've talked about
that what do you think is going on with
UFO we think there's a stigma so we
don't talk about it but actually
privately everyone wants to talk about
it so it's a collective illusion that
there's a stigma